hello everyone and welcome back to the
channel as you can see I've been growing
out this thick voluminous mustache and
coincidentally I don't know why I'm not
let into playgrounds anymore but anyways
today we're going to be talking about
stream processing and no I'm not talking
about R Kelly get your mind out of the
gutter I will be talking about the
architecture of message Brokers so I
have to go in about 10 minutes so let's
get into it and get started alright so
let's start this video with a quick
review of all the stream processing
stuff that we did in our last video
since it's been about a week due to my
10K special so basically to put things
very simply all stream processing really
is is we have two sets of nodes in our
system we've got producers and we've got
consumers and they communicate with one
another via events now we could send
those events directly and some ways of
stream processing do this you could send
them directly over TCP for example or
UDP or something like xeromq which works
on top of those but the majority of the
time what we want to be using is
something called a broker because it
handles the load of dealing with all of
those connections for us and we can
scale it you know kind of independently
of our producer and consumer nodes which
is great so there are two main types of
Brokers that we're going to talk about
today they've got two fundamentally
different types of architectures and
those are in-memory message Brokers
right over here and also log based
message broker so as you can see I've
listed a few different examples of
implementations of these so if you hear
someone talk about Kaka for example that
is a log based message broker
okay so what is an in-memory message
broker let's go ahead and get started by
talking about that well it's basically
exactly what it sounds like an in-memory
message broker is one that operates on a
server where specifically all of the
events are kept in memory so the way
that this works is as you can see we've
got something like this right here which
is a linked list
or we could implement it with an array
in memory or something like that but the
general gist is we want to you know be
representing a queue and so we've got
this queue of messages right here in
every single message that's what all of
these circles are gets sent to a
consumer and eventually what's going to
happen is once it gets sent to the
consumer it's actually going to be
deleted from the Queue at least
temporarily and then once the
acknowledgment comes back from the
consumer saying this thing is handled
then it really does get deleted from the
queue now you might be thinking to
yourself oh this is great we've got a
queue of all of these messages this must
mean that you know if this guy is before
this guy in the queue that this guy is
going to get processed before this guide
gets processed and that's not
necessarily true why is that the case
well keep in mind that when this guy
gets sent to a consumer for example
consumer one
this guy can instantly be sent to
Consumer too as long as consumer 2 is
ready for it it is not the case that we
necessarily need to wait for the
completion of processing of the prior
message before sending the subsequent
message to a different consumer we're
effectively using round robin message
delivery in order to ensure that we can
get the maximum possible throughput in
this situation
so for example if this network
connection is slow or it's just you know
hard to process this event
maybe it's asking to do something
particularly taxing on the consumer it's
possible that a message that is further
back in the queue gets completed before
and earlier one does so keep that in
mind so what's the kind of General
conclusion of something like an
in-memory message broker well basically
again we're using round robin delivery
in order to maximize our throughput but
what that can lead to is out of order
processing the only way to ensure
getting in-order processing is by doing
something called fan out where instead
of having basically
multiple consumers for a given queue
what we would actually do is make a
second cue over here and this could be a
second partition for example and then we
would have you know consumer one
exclusively reading from this top queue
exclu consumer two exclusively reading
from the bottom queue but that kind of
defeats the point because we want to
maximize our throughput
okay so the other thing is that messages
in memory are actually going to be
deleted like I mentioned when they're
processed successfully we get rid of
them we don't think about them ever
again we literally erase them from
memory or garbage collect them so what
that implies is that we have poor fault
tolerance if this machine were to go
down unless we have something like a
right ahead log to write all of our
events to disk we're just going to lose
all of these events and additionally of
course we can't replay these messages
because we're deleting them once they
are consumed
of course instead of using a right ahead
log though which you know is going to
slow our rights down a little bit
because rights to memory are always
faster than rights to disk what we could
instead just do is effectively the same
thing as using a redhead log which is a
log based message broker so here's what
that is going to look like as you can
see we've got all of this stuff right
here which is on disk and of course
those are going to be sequential rights
and sequential rights on disk are faster
than random ones so let's say we've got
you know these four messages and they're
next to one another on disk
what a log based message broker will
actually do is make sure that all of
these messages are held in the exact
order in which they came in if a new
message were to come in message five
it would be written at the back of the
queue over here sequentially blah blah
blah sorry that right is uh not really
popping through but the point is in
addition to basically keeping everything
sequential log based message Brokers
will also ensure that all consumers read
the messages within a single queue in
the same order in which the messages are
stored so as you can see what the log
base message broker will do is actually
store the location of the last message
that each consumer is has read so for
example let's say consumer B is now
going to read message 2.
so it's going to process this it's going
to acknowledge that it was processed
back to the message broker then what the
message broker will do is now say okay
if we're going to send consumer B
another message the next one it's going
to receive is message three so there's
no kind of round robin to be done over
here in fact if we wanted to increase
our throughput at all between consumer a
and consumer B what we'd have to do is
create a second broker up here and then
consumer a could start reading from that
and then consumer B would still be
reading from this guy over here
now note that because we have to read
every single message in the queue in
order that does technically lower our
throughput the reason being let's say
that message 3
is hard to read
or I shouldn't even say hard to read but
let's say it's hard to process would be
the better term you know whatever it is
that it's making us do is kind of
expensive and Now consumer B is going to
do that so it's going to process
let's say that whole thing takes 60
Seconds
it means that it's going to be an
additional 60 seconds before all of the
remaining messages in the queue are
processed so any slow message is going
to be a bottleneck for all of the others
so that is very important it slows the
processing of the rest and we would have
to partition our queue with additional
consumers reading from other partitions
in order to increase throughput
at the same time the really nice thing
about the log based message broker is
that our messages are durable not only
are they on disk if our machine were to
go down but more importantly we don't
actually delete them once we've read
them and what that means is that if for
whatever reason we want to add an
additional consumer in the future to
reread those messages or perhaps we're
just convinced that we missed a message
in one place or another we can actually
just reread them all and perform all of
our computations or processing again
so now that we've pretty much talked
about everything there is to know about
our log base message broker or something
resembling Kafka or AWS Kinesis let's do
a little bit of conclusion where we talk
about some scenarios where we would use
each type of broker
so keep in mind that in memory is
basically really really good if we want
maximum throughput it's really quick to
read and to write from memory but even
in addition to that we don't have single
messages in that queue being a
bottleneck we're delivering them in
round robin and as a result of this we
can ensure that basically every single
message is going to be processed as soon
as there's a consumer that's available
to process it that is really really
great at the same time though it means
that those messages are going to be
processed out of order and they're also
not durable for later availability this
is actually really useful for us in some
circumstances think about for example if
I'm a user and I'm posting videos to
YouTube and you know you're also a
YouTuber and you know your friend is a
YouTuber and every single time that we
upload a video to YouTube YouTube has to
basically encode it on its own back end
it doesn't really matter to YouTube
whether my video gets encoded first or
your video gets encoded first or your
friends video gets encoded first the
work just has to get done and then it
can be stored word in their database
somewhere or other the point is though
because that order doesn't matter
because they're not going to have to
redo the encoding work in the future and
they just want to encode as many videos
as humanly possible to decrease the
latency between what I post and when my
video is actually available then the
in-memory broker is really really good
for them a similar type of situation
would be something like Twitter where if
you're familiar with how you actually
would design a site like Twitter users
typically tend to make a bunch of posts
and those posts are then delivered to
all of their followers dedicated cache
which represents their news feed now of
course if I post you know half a second
before you it doesn't really matter at
the end of the day whether my message
gets into the cache before yours does so
of course in that case something like an
in-memory broker is totally fine
at the same time there are a lot of
situations where a log-based message
broker would be really really great the
first that I'm thinking of is sensor
metrics the reason being sometimes the
order of these really matters let's say
we want to calculate something like a
trailing average of the last 20 events
well if I were to start processing the
events out of order that would be pretty
problematic for actually ensuring the
validity of my results this is also good
if say you know we currently use a
normal average but eventually we want to
move to an exponential moving average
and we want to have all of those metrics
available still having those messages
replayable and on disk in Kafka or
Kinesis means that we can go ahead and
do additional calculations down the line
another example would be each write from
a database that you know we're taking
all of those rights for example and
putting them into a search index so in
our last video this was called change
data capture so in change data capture
obviously it's very important that the
The Ordering of the rights of the
database are preserved because let's say
I say x equals five and then I say X
equals seven well that's very different
than if I said x equals seven and then I
overwrote that with x equals five so
it's very important in a situation like
change data capture to preserve the
order of our events and also if you want
to add new derived data sources down the
line it would be great if those events
didn't get deleted the second we put
them in our search index hence something
like a log based message queue is a
really appropriate Choice here anyways
guys hope this makes sense I gotta run
because I'm about to go hit some dangers
have an intramural softball game so I
will see you all this weekend